[Musica]
la cosa di cui parlerà oggi in realtà
riguarda molte delle cose che faccio
l'insegnante l'assessore alla cultura lo
scrittore giornalista de la cittadinanza
italiana e la nostra cittadinanza e
questo articolo qui è l'articolo se come
quello che mi piace di più della
costituzione insomma se voi avete
presente un po la costituzione
ovviamente si tiene un po tutte insieme
ma la cosa più bella è evidentemente
appunto il l'idea che ci sono degli
articoli che sono più radicali di altri
e lo vorrei leggere insieme a voi questo
articolo tutti i cittadini hanno pari
dignità sociale e sono uguali davanti
alla legge senza distinzione di sesso di
razza di lingua di religione di opinioni
politiche di condizioni personali e
sociali
è compito della repubblica rimuovere gli
ostacoli di ordine economico e sociale
che limitando di fatto la libertà e
l'uguaglianza dei cittadini impediscono
il pieno sviluppo della persona umana e
l'effettiva partecipazione di tutti i
lavoratori all'organizzazione politica
economica e sociale del paese
la prima parte è bellissima e c'è quella
senza distinzione che è una parola
meravigliosa ma nella seconda parte ci
sono tre parole che mi stanno
particolarmente a cuore
la prima è compito perché i padri
costituzionalisti hanno scelto compito
che una parola scolastica non c'è
scritto e dovere e responsabilità e
ufficio e ambizione compito e computer e
le pubbliche fra nostra di rimuovere gli
ostacoli perché il compito una cosa che
va cominciata la portata in avanti e va
conclusa i compiti che appunto ci
vengono assegnati a casa i compiti che
assegniamo quando facciamo gli
insegnanti sono proprio quello è un
compito non è sarebbe meglio non è forse
si può fare non è un dovere interiore
compito e poi con l'altra parola che
anche è una parola molto forte rimuovere
gli ostacoli non dice che bisogna
evitare gli ostacoli diminuire scansare
rimuovere una parola che appunto come
dire all'articolo 3 della costituzione è
una parola molto
grossa rimuovere noi la usiamo quando
appunto si rimuovono la macchina che
evidentemente è un bel dramma quando
rimuoviamo le macerie vuol dire che
devono essere spazzati via con gli
ostacoli non ce ne deve rimanere traccia
quando vediamo che la nostra macchina
non c'è non c'è niente che ci dica che
c'era qualcosa li quegli ostacoli devono
essere tolti rimossi non devono essere
eliminati non ci devono essere mai più
e poi c'è quest altra parola che
impediscono gli ostacoli che impediscono
il pieno sviluppo della persona umana
qui padri costituzionalisti hanno
discusso non tanto sulla parola da
mettere ma sul tempo verbale mettiamo il
congiuntivo
omettiamo l'indicativo sarebbe quasi più
come dire suonerebbe quasi meglio il
congiuntivo gli ostacoli che impediscono
il pieno sviluppo della persona umana
hanno scelto l'indicativo perché quegli
ostacoli ci sono ci sono nel 1946 ci
sono nel 2018
c'è chi nasce ricco e chi nasce povero
chi nasce in una famiglia che lo può
sostenere chi nasce invece in una
famiglia che non lo può sostenere chi
nasce con una disabilità e chi nasce
invece appunto con delle altre
opportunità quegli ostacoli impediscono
il pieno sviluppo della persona umana e
l'effettiva partecipazione allo stato se
la parola chiave di oggi eterotopia io
vedo in questo articolo l'idea di una
società che ci dobbiamo inventare è
l'articolo che dice che quello che
stiamo facendo oggi oggi in questo
momento dobbiamo trasformare la nostra
società in qualcosa che non c'è e lo
bisogna farlo perché c'è scritto che è
un compito e bisogna farlo in modo
drastico perché c'è scritto che bisogna
rimuovere e bisogna farlo perché c'è una
tua fotografia di disuguaglianza che va
abbattuta che va tolta
io vengo da
appunto dalla scuola e vengono appunto
da questo mondo che ha provato a fare
questa cosa ci sono state tante leggi
che hanno provato a fare questa cosa
stata la legge 180 che a porta ha chiuso
i manicomi sono state il servizio
sanitario nazionale che è allargato a
tutti la possibilità ci sono stati i
decreti delegati che hanno portato
dentro le persone la riforma della
scuola media unica le club di
eliminazione delle classi differenziali
c'è stata una storia che è andata in
questo modo qui e questa storia però non
può essere come in una storia del
passato non può essere una storia che in
qualche modo anzi tendiamo a cancellare
io penso che ci debba essere l'idea che
bisogna trash che non bisogna entrare in
una società ma bisogna in qualche modo
immaginarsi una società diversa
vi ho dei dati il 14 per cento dei
ragazzi italiani ha solo la terza media
finisce solo la terza media
in sicilia sono il 25 per cento in
sardegna sono il 25 per cento in alcune
aree interne sono il 30 da 18 e 29 anni
il 25,7 per cento dei ragazzi non studia
non lavora non è nessun tipo di
formazione
la fotografia che viene fuori è come se
qui ci avessimo un teatro con 1.200
persone
e poi c'è un pezzo di società invisibile
che non c'è un altro quarto di società
un altro terzo di società che non è
incluso
ecco il nostro compito è includere quel
pezzo lì è quello delle persone che non
hanno cittadinanza che sono straniere e
includere le persone che sono che non
hanno la possibilità di permettersi uno
studio la ricerca e l'università
bisogna includere quei pezzi di società
mancanti perché il nostro compito
ma su questo
in realtà come dire
cioè come se ci fosse una pigrizia
spesso in questi giorni sentiamo parlare
della parola tradizione
sfogliate la la costituzione italiana
non c'è scritto da nessuna parte
tradizione la costituzione italiana è
rivoluzionaria è dinamica e
trasformativa vuole un mondo diverso non
vuole in qualche modo dare una struttura
di mondovì rimanga così e questo si vede
nella scuola per fortuna io tutti i
giorni quando lavora in classe racconto
la storia di dissidenti di eretici
racconto la storia di socrate cieli uno
condannato a morte per corruzione dei
giovani racconta la storia di galileo
condannata all'esilio racconto la storia
di chi ha inventato le utopie thomas
morr condannata a morte tommaso
campanella 27 anni in galera a scrivere
la città del sole raccontano storie
terroristi come mazzini 1 che cercava di
fare degli attentati contro l'ordine
costituito che nel 1875 quando muore
muore sotto falso nome inglese
quindici anni dopo l'unità d'italia e
non ai funerali di stato
io racconto la storia di persone che non
stavano nel loro tempo ma che hanno
immaginato un tempo diverso
non racconto la storia della tradizione
racconta la storia di persone che hanno
lottato contro la società del tempo
per questo quando per esempio a scuola
sento queste parole selezione eccellenza
meritocrazia
mi viene appunto dico ma questa non è la
scuola
sapete chi ha inventato il termine
meritocrazia michael young 1958 un libro
che si chiama the rise of meritocrazia
l'avvento delle meritocrazia questo
libro si immagina la distopia appunto è
un'utopia
nel 2050 quindi cento anni dopo quando è
stato scritto sì immagino un governo dei
meritocratici
finalmente la democrazia è stata
superata dalla meritocrazia
cosa succede a questa società il caos
disastro per due ragioni
la prima secondo me è più forte e cioè e
gli stupidi e chi non ce la fa e chi è
più fragile e chi rimane indietro
che ne facciamo li scansiamo limitiamo è
questa la parola che si sentono i miei
studenti va bene eccellenza va bene
meritocrazia ma se sono io quello che
non ce la fa se sono io quello che non
arriva primo se sono io quello che è
escluso e la seconda ragione è chi li
sceglie e meritocratici
e chiaro che per essere meritocratici
come dire bisogna aderire forse a un
disegno di qualcuno che in quel momento
detiene il potere l'ambiente della
meritocrazia finisce nell'anarchia
assoluta nella guerra civile
per queste ragioni semplici e quindi per
me quello che penso quello che credo che
dobbiamo fare è fare qualcosa di diverso
prendere l'esempio dei padri costituenti
dei disobbedienti civili
c'è una tradizione in italia di questo
che va da don milani dalla montessori da
franco basaglia da danilo dolci da
montanino bello c'è una tradizione che
appunto attraversa il campo socialista
il campo del cristianesimo più avvertito
il campo dei comunisti cioè quella
tradizione che ha messo insieme il pieno
sviluppo della persona umana che cos'è
il pieno sviluppo della persona umana
io la guardo e dico che cosa vuol dire
il pieno sviluppo della persona umana è
un'utopia il pieno sviluppo della
persona umana
c'è una frase che siamo una frase
fantascientifica la costituzione è una
cosa che difficilmente ci capita di
vedere nella nostra vita anche alla fine
della nostra vita diremo abbiamo avuto
il pieno sviluppo della nostra persona
quando ti chiamo dei figli qui in questo
momento stiamo avendo il pieno sviluppo
di questo ragazzo quando entrare in una
classe sto educando in modo che questi
ragazzi non l'abbiano pieno sviluppo
della loro persona non di mi dico mai di
sì
cosa c'è scritto lei che è compito è
compito non si può evitare di farlo è
compito non l'hai fatto vuol dire che
stai sbagliando
per questo appunto vi dico queste parole
come dire che avevo pensato diversamente
questo quando mi è stato chiesto di
partecipare sono stato contentissimo
qualche mese fa perché i tempi si
guastano e quindi quando i tempi si
guastano evidentemente abbiamo bisogno
non soltanto di maestri non soltanto dal
punto di ritrovarci nell'appartenenza ma
ne ho bisogno di questi spazi qui i
luoghi di discussione dei luoghi di
confronto abbiamo bisogno di di
laboratori di politica
questo è un laboratorio di politica
quando mi hanno detto qualche anno fa
che cosa avrei risposto oltre al teatro
una biblioteca alle persone che magari
appunto invece hanno fame le persone che
hanno bisogno di una casa
io ho detto un teatro e una biblioteca
perché penso che un teatro una
biblioteca portino poi il resto che il
teatro una biblioteca è quello che ci ha
insegnato unisce di civiltà dalla grecia
alla civiltà cinese è stranissimo come
in tutte le civiltà si sia sviluppato
l'idea che appunto abbiamo bisogno di
spazi politici di agorà di discutere
insieme di teatri e di biblioteche in
ogni civiltà parallelamente c'è questa
cosa
allora quello che io vorrei lasciarvi
quello che il compito che io mi do e che
magari ci rivediamo appunto fra qualche
anno in un'altra occasione che non sarà
un test ma sarà appunto un laboratorio
una sezione una parrocchia una piazza
eccetera eccetera ma in qualche modo
anche se non vi conosco anche se non
conosco nessuno di voi so che sto
parlando con persone che si sono presi a
fuori lo stesso compito perché questa
cosa qui mi da un senso di appartenenza
il test credo che sia questo non è uno
spettacolo ma appunto è un'assemblea
ecco l'idea che in questo momento e
soprattutto in italia magari ma appunto
in tanti paesi non ci sia un senso di
comunità
credo che questo articolo faccia
crescere invece questo senso di comunità
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]